this is what defeat looks like taliban
fighters in american uniform carrying
american weapons
inspecting american helicopters
just moments earlier the last u.s
soldier left afghan soil captured on
night vision camera ending 20 years of
war
the taliban fired shots of celebration
into the night sky
by dawn they were reorganizing making a
clear show they're back in control
the us aggression was a reckless act
from the beginning we told the americans
at the same time that they should not
invade our territory
the result was that now they were
defeated and the afghan people won the
battlefield and liberated their country
taking back the airport is symbolic for
the taliban in talks with turkey and
qatar about who will run it
but security is a sticking point
the last u.s aircraft to leave flew here
america's alluded air base in qatar
every aircraft you see here has been
involved in the frantic u.s departure
from afghanistan
nearly half of all the 120 000 evacuees
were brought through here
it's been an emotional two weeks for the
officer in charge think about the
magnitude of what we've done shepherded
through this installation more than 55
000 people to to a better life to
freedom that has not been repeated
elsewhere in the course of human history
that i'm aware of it's extraordinary and
so right now i'm anchored to that and
how did you keep morale going among your
team when they saw the taliban take over
and then that awful attack which claimed
the lives of 13 us personnel well you
know first off my team
we have one element here it's called air
medical evacuation and so they rushed to
kabul to help bring those who were
injured uh to the treatment they need
and so we were proud to be part of that
as well
this is the human cost of military
withdrawal
thousands of afghans now refugees
without a home
waiting to be processed in a military
hangar
these families some of the very last to
leave
it's interagency we've got customs and
border patrol department of homeland
security
interpreters from all over that are
helping us speak the language and help
move the process along to eventually
get these folks onto a flight to better
places
the u.s says it will continue to assist
american passport holders to leave
afghanistan but it's no longer on their
terms kabul airport now closed and in
taliban hands
the u.s did not stay a moment longer
than the agreed deadline the last
aircraft leaving afghan airspace around
1am on the 31st of august
and as the wheels left the runway a long
chapter closed for america the taliban
declared victory and an uncertain future
began for the afghan people
the longest war in american history
ended in a desperate and deadly scramble
for the exit
but the test for the taliban now begins
if they can give afghans a life they
don't want to leave
sally lockwood sky news at aludade air
base in qatar